wow this is great this is great well
what is this what is this that's it
hey that's it looks like a toy model
hanging upside down while eating dinner
I got a question for you guys
Steve our landlord comes by a lot he's a
good dude
usually he comes by he's pretty quirky
but the other day came by and he was
definitely extra quirky watching videos
so I started talking about cameras
randomly I don't mean to make
assumptions here but Steve's an old
hippy is Steve a wise mad genius who's
found the true meaning of happiness in
his own life or is he hi is there a
difference zombi good so how do you kill
them when you're running around here
underwear you don't come packaged right
there don't you have a great big sake
you're walking around with a slung John
there that a little bit so much that
nobody can ignore it no seriously you're
walking around with the schlong Hank to
the point where people don't even want
to come near you cuz they might bump
into it or stumble the drip on it today
we are here to talk about our not
spider-man video what does that mean
it's a video where the whole world is
full of spider-man's and woman's except
for Peter Parker one person one person
not spider-man not spider-man and his
name isn't Peter Parker it's it's Parker
Peter cuz it's backwards got a great
idea we got a great script written by
Danny now we've got basically a
three-day schedule for this plus some
pickups that can happen any time here's
one thing and instead of going to this
we would go to Peter's room well we
don't want to be doing is to be going
across town but all that can happen on
this
are you a street hero seen without the
spider people so it's totally doable to
do all this on a single day day one
we're gonna be running all over the city
and then day two will be all in here the
Oscorp sandwich will shoot here with
smoke and scientists and stuff day three
is all the green screen stuff breaths
I'm busy right no it's not busy you're
gonna be doing a lot of the composition
here I don't know if you know that yeah
I know I can do that this whole video is
After Effects composition yeah okay
right now that is 2d technically still
so you're fine because but Ren's not
really gonna have a ton of time to work
on this he's as in like he's not gonna
have any time to work I think it's gonna
go well we've got a little bit to shoot
on each day but I think we've got it
planned out didn't utilize our resources
the best way possible we'll see how it
goes
top secret documents guys guys thanks to
Sachs underwear today for sponsoring
this video you know why because today we
announce a breakthrough in human history
you may remember a man who went by the
name of Levi Strauss back in the gold
rush days of Southern California well
Northern California whatever doesn't
matter
point is he invented the jeans okay and
you know he did that using some canvas
from an old tent ooh that he'd never put
together and he started selling them and
now today everyone's wearing jeans and
today the same thing is happening
because there's a little company called
Sachs underwear they created this thing
called the ballpark pouch it makes you
feel like you're wearing nothing at all
okay and that's just really really
fantastic I'm immediately in a better
mood I've had these long Betty's on for
an hour and I feel more comfortable now
than I ever have wearing a pair of
underwear that's the truth I'm not I'm
not even I'm not exaggerating I'm not
making it up feel like I mean I feel I
feel free pay attention because there's
only so many moments in human history
where this sort of thing happens when
Steve Jobs introduced the iPhone when
levi-strauss invented the jeans when
Edison invented the light bulb I mean
heck even the wheel I feel so free
wearing these I know in the future this
is what the wear on Mars
sex underwear is available in over fifty
four colors and prints they also sell
lounge pants trunks shirts so head on
over to sacs underwear calm and use the
promo code Sam and Nico to get five
dollars plus free shipping of your first
purchase that's it that's all I have to
say carry on explain to me what the hell
of very campus sonic I thought the
VariCam was Sony Panasonic it's there
it's there cinema camera it's beautiful
that's what they shot better call Saul
they shot yeah and they hey it's not
that big it's no bigger than the red and
I'll tell you what they did they found
that they
use it when they couldn't get into when
it was really tough to reach places and
get down on to like if they were
suddenly down here like this
yeah shooting a scene up like right like
this a shot up real quick get the shot a
cutter with it's only in the last three
seconds and editing anyway
shoot that [ __ ] and then get back and
get and use the of their other cameras
but they said the great thing about the
very camp was that it was incredibly low
light and that they were able to shoot
with literally go on a streets that had
already been lit up by the city yeah
with just streetlights have you have you
seen master of none uh Netflix do this
yeah yeah the whole thing's I'm very Kim
it is with what's his name and see males
re so you know normal normally cameras
have like a a bass is oh right right
right
the bass is so on this apparently is
like 5,000 or something kinda it has to
805 that's it hey that's it they said it
has eight hundred and five thousand you
can so you can shoot during the day and
have a clean full dynamic range and wide
go all the way up to five thousand they
get super clean again I love the idea if
not have I mean the the more you can
shoot low light the less you have to
have a Jenny around and and run cable
and the less you have to set up lights
and kicks down the street I mean you
could have a bare minimum package yeah
the barest minimum package and and you
know with some battery-powered [ __ ] to
be able to put that's what the VariCam
yeah god that's near that definition
going down the stream and and look
you're not having to have some guy go
wow that's natural light on the arch
watch this
better call Saul they had a scene in
which they shot the foreground of a guy
on a bridge going down to make a drug
deal down in a tunnel
east and it was just unbelievably well
lit and the DP didn't put any light on
it was the chef what's uh
crowd shouting in tunnel oh god it's
called better it also no no but it's a
bridge shot yeah nice and rich nighttime
bridge go to that shot that's it no no
no no no no no no Saul gained darkness
what what is this what is this what is
this great look at that don't live by
the phone yeah it's the phone look at it
and it's crystal clear when you're
watching it on a big screen it's crystal
clear there's no breakup there's no gain
no there's a shot yeah there it is go do
it
those are taught two totally different
shots look how beautiful that looks
multi-coloured City of Albuquerque and
what this almost looks like a toy model
all jokes aside Steve if you're watching
this you're a great dude we love you and
come on by anytime man Danny wrote this
really great video about how there's
like a kid who is not spider-man well
everyone in the world is spider-man
problem is we have a scene in this in
the video that requires people to be
hanging upside down while eating dinner
and quite frankly we just don't really
have the budget to pull it off safely
and I don't want to try to jank on this
because if you do it incorrectly
someone's gonna fall on their neck when
I originally wrote the script I wrote it
without thinking about how we would
actually accomplish everything in the
script
and now as we're getting closer to
shooting it we're ending up having to
cut a decent amount so that we can
actually shoot it and rework parts of
the story around that no they're going
so far Anika I'm good just trying to mix
blend of Danny's magic with Jake's
practicality so that we have a suitable
video that's fine stuff also the Neko
magic sprinkled on one of the challenges
I think I'm gonna face in this is just
directing such an ambitious piece for
like one of my first bigger things I
mean the only thing that I've really
directed that's anywhere near this
ambitious before is the the
kylo Ren workout plan thing that we did
we knocked out a few hours this is gonna
be like several locations several scenes
I'm working with someone who's shooting
this Nico only I've only worked with
Nico once before I'm really excited
about it because I know Nico shoots
really well and I'm excited to give
directing a shot but this is our first
time working together in this way I hope
that it can go smoothly
mostly I'm worried about my own
directing will I be able to clearly
direct Nico to shoot the scenes in the
way that I envisioned them in my head
when everyone became spider-man in this
world there's a shortage of costumes
tell me more
even as a billionaire newspaper man I've
been forced to wear a $40 Halloween
costume